la présidence française est elle sous
l'influencé des lobbys alors que la
france s'apprête à présider le conseil
de l'union européenne pour six mois à
compter du 1er janvier 2022 un rapport
abonde dans ce sens dans un document de
58 pages l ong corporate europe
observatory chez l'observatoire des
multinationales évoque les liaisons
dangereuses entre le gouvernement
français et de grandes entreprises la
présidence française se prépare en
collaboration étroite avec les grandes
entreprises françaises via des réunions
de lobbying des événements publics et
des demandes de contributions
d'associations d'entreprises et think
tank avec peu de transparence tandis que
la société civile et le grand public
sont tenus à distance relance puissance
appartenance c'est le slogan de la
présidence française trois mots liés au
concept de souveraineté devenu
omniprésent dans le discours français
sur l'europe force est constater que la
définition a quelque peu évolué les
cabinets de lobbying basé à paris et
bruxelles travaille depuis des mois à
tisser des liens entre décideurs publics
et des représentants d'entreprises à
travers des conférences publiques et des
discussions privées parmi ces cabinets
de lobbying à tenora organise des
rencontres entre des entreprises
françaises et des décideurs clés à
travers son cercle des réseaux européens
dont les membres comprennent les plus
grandes entreprises françaises telles
que total energy orange bouygues renault
et air france klm entre autres si
l'exécutif français n'a rien à se
reprocher pourquoi ce manque de
transparence concernant ces rendez vous
avec de grands groupes privés interroge
le rapport sur 38 réunion de lobbing
dévoilé par le représentant de la france
à bruxelles 28 l'ont été avec des
entreprises ou des lobbys industriels
contre seulement 2 avec la société
civile les cas de pantouflage ou de
rétro pantouflage à des postes clés
c'est à dire les allers retours entre
les secteurs public et privé sont
également pointés du doigt l'autre moyen
clé d'affluence pour les entreprises et
leur lobby consiste à recruter d'anciens
fonctionnaires européens ou français
travaillant sur les politiques
européennes
pour accéder aux hautes sphères
politiques et bénéficier de leurs
expériences et connaissances par exemple
pour savoir qui contacter et caen afin
d'influencer certaines décisions un
phénomène assez répandu dans les
capitales européennes mais aussi à
bruxelles parmi les exemples les plus
connus l'ancien président de la
commission européenne josé manuel
barroso
employé par goldman sachs ou encore
l'ancien commissaire neelie kroes qui a
rejoint hubert en 2019 avec le soutien
d' emmanuel macron est thierry breton
est nommé commissaire européen pour le
marché intérieur thierry breton qui est
donc passé de pdg d'atos entreprise
française de technologie numérique et de
conseil un des postes les plus hauts de
la commission européenne le recours à
des sponsors privés pour financer une
présidence pose question également qu'il
s'agisse de dons financiers ou de biens
et services gratuits et quasiment toutes
les présidences récentes ont été
parrainés par coca cola microsoft et bmw
ou d'autres grandes entreprises le
secrétaire d'état français chargé des
affaires européennes minimise
l'importance du sponsoring je prends un
exemple très concret car un constructeur
automobile français près des voitures
électriques pour un événement parce que
cela rentre par ailleurs dans nos
priorités pour le climat c'est le
maximum que l'on autoriserait en terme
d'implication du monde de l'entreprise
sauf que ledit constructeur renault fait
mise en examen pour tromperie dans la
sphère du diesel gates avec des soupçons
de trucage de tests anti pollution sais
pas si reluisant renault qui va fournir
220 véhicules électriques et hybrides
pour transporter les délégations de
ministres européens pendant six mois le
prêt dont ou financement d'une
présidence n'a pas toujours pour seul
objectif d'améliorer l'image de ladite
entreprise la relance post covit de l'ue
vise à favoriser une augmentation
majeure de la production de véhicules
électriques et des infrastructures de
recharge tandis que de nouveaux
objectifs de pollution pour les
véhicules sont discutés à bruxelles il
n'est pas difficile
jean et comment le don de voitures
électriques à une présidence du conseil
fait partie d'une stratégie bien plus
larges de l'industrie automobile pour
influencé l'élaboration des politiques
de l'ue comment faire confiance aux
décisions publiques lorsque des intérêts
privés entrent en compte sponsor
partenariat douteux pantouflage en
matière de transparence et d'intégrité
la politique en général a encore
beaucoup à apprendre